today sony announced that PlayStation VR  will have 50 games out before the end of  the year and the virtual reality system  itself will arrive on octobre 13 for 399  bucks as for what you'll get to play  sony showed off our first look at  capcom's resident evil 7 biohazard and  the trailer is exactly as creepy and  unsettling as you hope the game is  slated to release on January 24 and a  demo will be available today for  PlayStation Plus subscribers to download  and play on ps4 also announced was a  blink-and-you'll-miss-it teaser trailer  for a Batman Arkham vr exclusive which  is due out this October if you still  haven't got your VR fill it was also  revealed that you'll be able to play  Final Fantasy 15 in VR as one of the  game's protagonists posto been used on  all the PSB our games we know about so  far be sure to stop by games but  you